you know what I wish we could just have
my companion here to tell the story of
the review that we would give okay so we
have just gone and seen Ant Man and the
wasp and we're going to apologize in
advance if there's a lot of yawning it
is past midnight we had to go to elation
but it it was like you know and if we
sat through you know hours later emerge
look just so so yeah for those of you
who might be tuning in who are not aware
this is Liz this is my partner and also
my co-host on the punch like a girl
podcast where we reviewed where we did
we review not all that long ago the
volume one of the Train collection of
the unstoppable wasp which is a
different character from either of the
two versions of the wasps that are in
this movie movie what so ever unlike a
you know that was an hour set and
anyways that's a diverse wings
oh boy this is a good time we're tangent
Inc already uh-huh we'll try to avoid
spoilers for as long as we can but we
are gonna get to them eventually so but
let's let's start without getting into
specifics of plot general feelings how
did you like it
I liked it it was fun I have a lot of
things a lot of notes and a lot I felt
like it was there was too much going on
and it was a little convoluted I feel
like they're they almost had too much
power
like hmm there is too much they could do
and the science with such mush well yes
I mean mushy in the first one I just
watched the first one last night and
this morning and that was that was your
first time haven't seen the first time
this was like oatmeal
yet but wasn't that sandy oatmeal from
the packets the that's why I made that
reference yeah a little so my thoughts
are not dissimilar from yours it's not
bad it's fun at times there are sections
that are very good mm-hmm some good
fight scenes yeah I think the action was
really the highlight in this one but it
I come away going boy I feel like I have
a lot of notes but at the same time the
film is so unambitious sounds like more
of a slight than I mean it to be but
it's not aiming for anything deep and I
almost feel like a jerk for pointing out
these things but it did it did feel like
I had a lot of things like well this and
this so that's the thing it's not aiming
for any one message or anything it feels
like and that's why it does feel a
little scatter shot that's what I think
I think the thing for me is it lacks
focus because the the first film comes
in you have you know Scott stumbles into
this but the goal is very clear get this
stuff away from Darren cross simple and
everything revolves around that in this
one we have a we have our heroes and
what they're trying to do and then we
basically have three sets of
complications that keep stumbling into
that one being the villain ghosts one
being the FBI now we're I'm talking just
sort of the elements that play here
on one being the FBI agents because
Scott's still supposed to be under house
arrest
mm-hmm and then the other being like
this third faction that just is
interested in stuff that's going on for
their own financial
they weren't that cool tech without
really understanding what it is yeah but
you've got these three element and but
they are not actually integral to the
goals of the heroes they're just the
obstacles so it doesn't own it together
we don't have villains go we don't have
heroes going up against villains we have
heroes trying to achieve a goal with
villains who just won't leave them alone
and that's just not particularly
compelling no I I have a feeling we're
going to be mostly nitpicking from here
off I don't know about you I don't
regret seeing it okay so here's another
positive note I will see for the first
one so Paul Rudd is a likable actor and
but I tend to like him more in sort of
secondary roles or as like sort of an
off offshoot not an offshoot love
interest the love interest like he is in
clueless I like him in that okay I just
as a leading man I don't think he's bad
I just don't think he has I don't know
what it is that it didn't you say this
was going to be a positive no no no but
that's what I okay yeah okay so I really
felt that way I really felt that way in
the first movie and I was like he's okay
but he's just not quite clicking for me
this I really liked him a lot better
he was funnier he seemed to just kind of
the fact that he the fact that the wasp
could do more I was gonna say he's up
he's not carrying as much of the movie
this time he wasn't but he was better in
the role and I think he felt more
comfortable in it and in the goofier
parts but also in the more heartfelt
part like he was great when he was
taking on the persona of the mother oh
yeah yeah we are we are firmly into
spoilers at this point folks yes Janet
okay sorry I was like there's so many
different names in my room
from the comics or from okay so he takes
on her like I thought he was great in
that and it was so funny and just like
that like softer mannerisms and like the
taking both their hands and like I
thought he did it well without it being
too over-the-top and like you know
offensive in a way you know
okay so so sort of for me like the the
major highlights by far were the action
scenes yeah I mean I was sitting you
heard me like laughing out loud and
they're like oh like during those
actresses the car chase especially was
realizing now that was phenomenal the
kitchen fight was good that was probably
my favorite I like the car chase a
little bit better but the kitchen fight
was really good I feel like there was a
lot of creativity put into into those
those bits but I
oh and I like the bit where he has the
like trailer truck and he's like yeah so
yeah I think here's ultimately the thing
like I said the the villains are just
kind of in the way because their goal is
to get Janet back mm-hmm and then it's
just all these things that make that
hard to do but they they aren't organic
obviously it's not like your it's not
like they're on a quest and in order to
complete the quest they must overcome
these things like they're on a very
straightforward quest and things that
have nothing to do with this quest just
keep interjecting and then they have to
deal that I think it says a lot about
the fact that I think the conflict that
I was most invested in mm-hmm
was in worrying about Scott getting
caught breaking his house arrest and
that he'd have his daughter taken away I
was way more worried about that than
anything else going on this movie and
take that as you will both in the sense
of it meant that that was well sold but
also that probably was not the part I
was supposed to be most worried about
but as a father that makes sense for you
yes but the thing is but the pain
stuff didn't connect with me that hard
in the first movie oh okay
I think they did thread that throughout
the movie well with the fact that you
know like they established that early on
with his like foot going through the
fence and you know like the fact that he
had it set up for the Cheyenne to play
the job to take a back and like you know
basically sort of be his proxy for
everything yeah
and they kept going back to that and so
I think that worked well I was invested
in their actual quest because I'm Lee Ji
na equals Michelle Pfeiffer so obviously
it and it was well worth the payoff
because like she's it's great when you
first see her and it's like you know
thank effervescent isn't like from for
her in this I was invested in that um I
I love the actors who plays his daughter
she's great she's funny oh my gosh oh
yeah the the kid if they can yeah happy
um and she it's just great in the role I
loved our little rollercoaster ride and
their little maze like I think that
relationship was still really well
established and I liked it in the first
movie - in it I think they just built
upon it here and I think that I mean
Paul Rudd has really good chemistry with
that address - yes yeah he definitely
does um and just you know like the part
about the World's Greatest Dad and stuff
and her world world's grandma hold the
greatest grandma sorry and you are gonna
mess up some of the other stuff at play
um ghosts I like the look the suit was
really cool it was fun with 3d - we saw
it in 3d which normally we would I don't
think either of us is big on 3d but her
everything going on with her was very
cool in 3d uh-huh I think part of the
thing though this was part of the issue
with her as a villain aside from the
fact that she was very detached from the
quest that
they were on is the fact that ultimately
when whenever she got into a fight with
either a man or the wasp it just came
down to each of them keeps missing it's
just they keep missing her because their
punches go through through her she keeps
missing them because they shrink out of
the range of her punches so it's just
two people repeatedly failing to hit
each other
it is how those fights go what did you
think of her emotionally as a character
I like the idea I don't think they sold
it she kept mentioning how much things
hurt and I feel like they really needed
to put an emphasis on the fact that
whatever level of pain she endures it is
constant it is absolutely constant and
you know we can accept and I don't know
the reality of this stuff but we can
accept in movies you know that Chinese
water torture or whatever drives you mad
after what I don't know a day or
whatever if she's dealing with this
constant pain that she cannot correct
and cannot address I can buy that it
pushes her to the limits that she does
but that's sort of me extrapolating from
stuff that's in there so like I said I
like the concept I don't think they
actually sold it very well
I think her I really liked Bill Foster
because I he was good another which is
play who is played by Laurence Fishburne
because he the fact that he is helping
her and is like we're gonna help you but
the moment she's like I'm gonna go after
Cassie he's like no I'm done I will not
help you there and I thought that was
great because I was like technically
you're working with the villain but that
is a very like moral choice to make I
mean what I liked about their connection
uh-huh was that it was very clear that
he felt a kinship dur because as far as
he was concerned she was another victim
of Hank Femmes arrogance yeah which he
feels himself to be as well and I I have
found it actually very interesting the
way they've sort of thread the needle of
hank pym as a character because they
they have not shied away from the fact
that hank pym is kind of a dick but they
have it largely of a feature of his
history not to say that he's not still a
little rough around the edges but
without sugarcoating over what the guy
is like they also are not presenting it
upfront to the audiences as something's
like now which would frankly make him
unlikable
because hank pym he basically he was
destroyed as a character in the I think
it was the 80s
in a storyline that had a moment where
he struck Janet oh and and in the eyes
of comic book readers hank pym has never
recovered he has been he lasts 30 years
his forever been Hank Pym wife-beater
and the thing was that was another
variation ever well and see that's the
thing but that and this is not me saying
that people shouldn't hold that against
them but I'm saying that wasn't even the
intention of that moment the intention
of that moment was you know he was
losing his mind was what was it going on
but it reverberating on a level and
damaged the character way more than the
writers had ever intended which is a big
part of white hank pym is not ant-man
anymore and hasn't been for a very long
time because they couldn't sell him as a
hero again after that so what I've liked
about these movies this one especially I
think with characters like Bill and like
Ava who ghost
is that you you get you see the impact
of his arrogance of his selfishness of
his self-importance but it's a it's a
feature of his history as opposed to
something we have to deal with now where
would where it would make him be
unlikable and unable to be rooted for
which was what happened in the comic I
think it's a great role for Michael
Douglas yes
you want to talk about somebody with
with some nasty history now that we need
to not be dealing with right now cuz
otherwise you won't want to see him yes
he very much is Hank Pym he never plays
the straight-laced hero because no one
would ever buy him as that no
but I always believe he's very
intelligent and you know thinking three
steps ahead
yeah he's verifying he was he was
usually you know he plays that like
greedy corporate is like corrupt kinda
character he he always he was always a
good casting pick he was a good casting
pick in the previous one I think he yeah
hard to do this time yeah definitely um
I really thought that in the first one
like you know when he starts out the
first one like punching some guy I'm
like uses moments in the first one he's
kind of an exposition machine in the
first one he gonna have to be well yes
you have an origin story and like you
have to explain mushy science yeah so
it's funny like for as many for as much
as they're I can't I said earlier like I
had a lot of things that are like and
the things that I feel like I summed it
up just saying how ancillary the
obstacles were to the main goal of the
heroes and because I feel like pretty
much everything I had an issue with just
feeds back into that so now despite
having like almost set it up like I was
gonna have a list of nitpicks I should
kind of don't now cuz they're just
variations on making that point again I
will say that I really thought little
like guys who are coming to just steal
the tak
I really thought in a lot of ways they
were unnecessary yeah I'm not sure they
why I don't know what Wow okay I did
like I know whoo though the like people
who were supposed to be moderating Scott
he was adorable and their little like
back and forth yeah he was something
else I like fully incompetent I was
gonna say I know I was gonna say I don't
know why they're there but then I
realize I dunno why they're there they
were reverse engineered into the story
for the sake of the chasing because they
needed people that they could crash
their cars and crash their motorcycles
and it couldn't be the FBI guys after
Scott because they're just doing their
job so they needed a group unto be Anna
goes just and Bill didn't have that many
people yeah it doesn't make sense for
ghosts and Bill to have henchmen so I
will bet you that that those that entire
set of villains was reverse engineered
out of a desire to be able to have
disposable people to be to be enough in
these and the action scenes I don't even
know what now their names were there now
I just I don't know how to feel about
that now because it does make them
completely and utterly superfluous as
far as the story goes except that the
action scenes that cuz they were the
ones that the wasp was fighting in the
kitchen scene they were the ones that
they know I can't be hurried and I can't
be like take them out because then we
lose the best action scenes but I'm like
but it doesn't help us start ah I just
given the more reason or had them
connected to something greater and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe I don't know
you know what uh you know what could
have worked at least it would have it
would have made them feel less ancillary
uh-huh is maybe if Bill maybe instead of
Hank and hope getting parts from him
maybe bill have been trying to get parts
from him to help Ava and that was how he
caught on to the lab because otherwise
it's like oh this guy who they've been
dealing with just happens to be come a
problem at the same time that this ghost
thing shows up at the same time no Jim
I'm going on all that having as many
obstacles as they did justified having
as many people helping them as they did
like why they need a Louis and that team
as well and why you needed both ant-man
and the wasp and hey
you know working with them and
everything I mean there's a lot going on
and wheel spinning that it wears if
you're fighting just the one villain
like you don't need that you don't want
I think we I think there's a there's a
fundamental conflict between the villain
that they chose and the action scenes
that they wanted to do because they
chose a villain who is who acts alone
but then they have all these action
scenes that require a whole bunch of
other people yeah and so we end up with
a story that bends over backwards to
accommodate these things where I just
feel like they needed to they needed to
go back to the drawing board and come up
with yeah they needed they needed a
villain that complimented the action
scenes they wanted to do because they
had the lighting cuz like is that I mean
there are fights between ant-man the
wasp and ghost but it's a whole lot of
people missing each other I don't think
I might minded those five things as much
as you did but I will agree like the
kitchen scene was better and it's better
when you can land punches I feel like
the world was still cool and like i
specially felt that in the kitchen fight
of everything shrinking but it wasn't as
cool as in the first movie where you're
like seeing the miniature world for the
first time in Des Moines like I miss
going into like the ant burrows and
stuff like that that was really fun in
the first movie like there disconnect
from the ants yeah I think about that
like you didn't have that emotional
feeling you didn't have Anthony you
didn't have ants but you didn't have any
ant that he was like super connected
with and I kind of missed that as well
now that I'm thinking about it because I
can't just ask like a completely
superfluous question how common are the
drawn ants with the wings because it
seems like he could basically just judge
just jump up and land on one like are
they that super common cuz I guess
boobers he had civics Adam ants and they
introduced that in the first night yeah
man maybe it's been too long since I've
seen the first it just seemed like it
wasn't even a massive difference between
him and the wasp of the fact that she
had wings cuz he could just basically
jump and call an ant with wings at a
moment's notice that is the problem I
think and there was it with the first
movie too is like things are really
convenient and it really shows them this
movie and convenient things happen well
actually this movie does it both things
are really convenient or they're really
inconvenient because I but it's
convenient for the plot and you know
moving it along or the fight scene or
whatever that things are very convenient
so it's the lenient that it inconvenient
to being the convenience element that
bug the crap out of me was Scott's
malfunctioning suit I'm like there is no
reason for this thing to be like this
except that they want I thought they had
fixed it but apparently they have yeah
they wanted him to be at a disadvantage
in this fight they wanted to get you
know a bit of a funny gag out of him
being my guess about yay tall for a hot
man and he was in a school how funny
that when he was in a school yeah but
this is being accomplished through the
sheer bloody coincidence of this new
suit doesn't work well oh the wasps
works fine but his doesn't work well
because it's funnier when it happens to
him and yeah that that did annoy me that
that had that it does that was plot
convenience technical glitching to be
honest like probably Paul Rudd is
probably got a lot more comedic acting
under his belt than I am Julian really
I'm not saying he doesn't but that's but
vacuumer just acting I like her as an
actress don't get me wrong
that's just a really cheap way to set up
a gag it's a really a lazy way to force
commodore really kick it miss apart and
I don't think either one of us was like
really unhappy know what I mean I
I feel like we gave fair warning this is
probably what was gonna happen I need to
pick apart it's very fluffy and I don't
know if this analogy makes it very funny
I feel like you just keep picking the
lint off it until oh look there's just
the skeleton left oh whoops I did I
should have stopped picking that got
weird yes yeah I feel like I channel
break for just a second pair I really
like even though he really only did it
once I think this was my favorite
convoluted story Lois story like a whole
segue about you boxes you want a diamond
have you got a let him play oh man how
did you box
hello Morrissey Oh imagine like if they
just let him go there one there's part
of me that like they need to bring back
the Marvel one-shots because they used
to have these shorts that they would
release every now and then they'd be
between they need to bring back the
Marvel one-shots just so we can find out
what's the longest that we could stretch
LOL lewis narrated MCU adventure so far
I'm pretty sure you couldn't get away
with it for a feature film I bet you
could get you you could just make it
work for like say 12 minutes yeah I was
thinking 15 yeah and I'm like I just
love them all
you know lip synching to his wife and I
can be like and she said and he was
feeling like this I think like it was so
great oh especially his take on the like
Scott hope love story so
how how were you on their romantic
connection um because I was kind of if I
felt like it was okay so at the end of
the first they establish they don't hate
each other but they're making out and
then it they work as partners and
fighting partners but I just don't feel
like they skip the step between and I
guess sometimes there's like not a step
between hating each other and then
banging each other there but I feel like
there should be well it's not ever gonna
go from being mad at each other to
banging each other again
they they they skipped it but alluded to
it because basically they skipped a
whole chunk of the courtship between
movies but referred back to it as having
happened between the movies at this
point like I said I am starting to feel
bad for picking on as much as we are
because it's not it's not like it's this
big ambitious piece it's very much what
the first one was it's a palate cleanser
after a heavy movie from from this thing
and I don't know I cut it I wish they
had at least try not tried to do so much
with all these different obstacles so we
could feel one of the story's deeper
either what ghost was going through
emotionally and deepening that
connection with Bill because I felt they
did have a good connection they did or
you know really they did a good job with
the Janet and Hank and like you know
hope looking for her mother and that
connection but if they had chosen one of
those as an emotional arc to follow
through an emotional story to follow
through with the movie I would have been
happier with that yeah I mean I think
ultimately for me this this was a movie
that was fine while it lasted doesn't
hold up to much scrutiny at all yeah
it was it fun I probably don't need to
see it again but yeah I would watch the
kitchen side again and Louis this story
again well I mean I'd watch a
compilation of his of his stories
definitely I think there is out there
like a video that's like olive I was
gonna say I think I think as soon as I
stop recording I'm gonna see if I can
find a compilation on YouTube of Louis
stories okay so I think we'll wrap it up
um so yeah Liz thank you for staying up
what another half hour or so
just to sit down in Yammer with me and
thank you folks for watching what what
Morgan I want to thank you for being the
world's greatest grandma I really do
then I should get you chuck
I came from the heart so heavy who's
seen ant-man and the wasp what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it I'm not even going
to go through listing all the stuff you
know what the stuff is there's links
board down below the patrons the big one
that's all I'll say
so until next time this council is
adjourned
don't snicker at my sign-off yeah I know
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]